here with jeffrey morgan where we left
off we were kind of making that
transition from the
uh from the invention to the the the
structuring
the organized organization yeah and in
fact if you can kind of
show if you go down to the corner here
show that toulmin model thing
so this was a this tillman model idea
was kind of like a unit of organization
this is actually might even be thinking
about as the skeleton of a paragraph
so usually we use we've been taught to
use do this with outlining
and i think we ought to try to translate
this model into an outline model
okay so if you just go like right over
in the middle here okay and you sort of
say like a roman numeral
one or something the big thing you know
the thing you always put the top of the
airline whatever the heck that is
um that might be our thesis sentence so
so
maybe i'll just copy and paste oh
because that's pretty cool that's right
so let's just
uh okay let's copy and let's just paste
that down
okay all right all right i'll rewrite
the roman numeral one
okay cool very cool yeah yeah there you
go this is our roman numeral
okay and now if you have that sort of
abc thing yeah
so so the a thing would be our first
topic sentence now we agreed that
there's going to be
an argument we're going to have one
paragraph is going to be about
something about the motivation of
officials so let's just just take that
much for the time being
okay we don't have a claim about it yet
okay but we just put that
kind of somewhere around a so right i
didn't
write a big claim yeah yeah the
motivations of are
they are good exactly exactly exactly i
want to write something about it right
so
we have a topic with no claim but we'll
go back and we'll create a sentence
a claim here in just a second so put
that one there okay then we got one that
says state mandates might help a
classroom that's really broken
couldn't help so that would be b might
have yeah we should probably ship
it probably made that red thing okay
i'll put both of them here state
mandates there you go okay
so i'll copy and i'll paste that
statement so i'm going to leave some
space because this is going to be a
different yeah not not here you can put
it all together
we'll we'll i'll make you change it
later okay state mandates
okay and then might help yeah
might help a classroom that is really
broken right
so and it's interesting to watch i think
our attitude toward that has got
increasingly skeptical
but but we're we're putting it there
because that's going to be a b
right right so that'll be like that's a
b and then we have another one which is
state mandates hold back more
successfully performing classrooms right
so that's another one so let me see hold
back so it's going to be hard for me to
copy and paste properly yeah
so i just write that down actually well
you know what's interesting and by the
way it isn't really statement
it's it's more like micromanaging i mean
when we got to that last point that was
your real point
so i know okay micro management
and then hold back so then we also have
micromanaging micro i'll just write
micro yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're cool might hold back
yeah exactly are definitely
going to hold back more successful class
exactly exactly micromanage
okay hold back yep there you go
success we we obviously have to do that
and then there's probably one more
around and maybe it's even more than one
paragraph around
alternate solutions right but let's just
for the moment assume it's just going to
be one paragraph okay
uh on alternate solutions so now you see
what we did
so what's happened now is we now we're
getting we're getting pretty organized
we don't know exactly what's going to go
in these buckets but we've got some
buckets
and and we may actually change the order
of the buckets
but basically the idea behind this is if
we
fill the four buckets under a b c and d
we will have effectively proven the
claim
in roman numeral one that these are
actually going to be
these are taking that claim and breaking
it into parts
and then each part we have to prove if
we go back to our toolman model
the way we're going to prove it is we're
going to provide evidence for each claim
and what logic warrants the belief that
that evidence
should lead a reasonable person to
accept that claim so the way this is
going to really evolve into our essay
is that this thesis sentence i thought
it was very interesting when you
highlight the difference between an
introduction and a thesis
that a thesis is like okay this is the
point that i'm going to be doing
introduction is kind of getting us into
the
into the mood so to speak of of what
we're talking about
and when we have the the step after or
so we said invention
organization the one the next one's
going to be called drafting
when we do drafting we're going to draft
an introductory paragraph which is going
to do exactly what you said
when you draft an introductory paragraph
you know where it ends
because it's going to end with a thesis
sentence right and then you have to
think about
well where do i start to reach out and
capture the
the interests of my audience and then
how many what's the fewest number of
sentences
i can write to get from where i think
they are to where they would be
interested in reading that sentence
right right
yeah and so that could this is kind of
going to end up in the draft phase
probably being the skeleton of our first
paragraph that's correct and then each
of these are going to be
our our next paragraphs that's correct
that's correct actually in the draft
this is the last sentence of our first
paragraph that that the number that
yeah this is the point you you lead this
is what
and everything after this sentence is
totally in service to that
that's what's cool about thesis and
topic sentences and then for each of
these we're going to just try to think
okay like what you know
we're going to make a claim in this this
paragraph a i haven't made a claim yet
the motivations of administrators and
officials
i i'll make the claim now are well
intentioned okay so great so let's just
do that our well-intentioned our
well-intentioned okay so that's a claim
so now let's go back over to our toulmin
model and we say okay that's a claim
what evidence do you have that they're
well intentioned
well once again here it's it's anecdotal
um
it's it's my interactions with
administrators and officials
they're all good human beings uh they
all
you know they're not trying to make
other people's life harder
they genuinely are trying to improve
outcomes for students
they generally care about this as an
issue at a state level or national level
so let me just push on this just a
little bit
how many and you've been doing khan
academy for how long
uh well i i mean invisibly too visibly
well depending on how you want to think
about it i mean you know
we got our office base about three years
ago okay so and in
in that time period how many
administrators or officials do you think
you've had
interactions with i probably need one a
week okay so you saw
maybe as many as 100 right okay so so
you have an enormous amount of
credibility when you
say these people are well-intentioned
you have a hundred examples now you're
not gonna name
names right right but but you have 100
examples so therefore i think and i
think you should put that
in your paragraph because that's what
warrants
me believing that that your evidence
validates the claim yeah and and and
when when a person has
special experience of their own
sometimes you just say
you know you tell an anecdote as you
said i remember talking to bill gates or
i remember talking to so and so
and they said such and such and and that
that's
another kind of evidence and another
kind of warrant and maybe it's the fact
that it's a famous person
or maybe it's just the fact that it's a
really clear example that people go
okay i'm willing to grant your claim but
until
you give me something all you've done is
made a claim you have not proven that
right
right so it could just be my example
i've i just yeah it is anecdotal but
it's from
a position maybe of some type of
authority anecdotes are
are a legitimate form of evidence
particularly in the humanities
in the hard sciences anecdotes are
probably not a legitimate form of
evidence and you really do have to show
data test data clinical trial data if
you're a pharma you can't just say
somebody took my medicine and they got
better but no i mean for a claim like
this the motivations of administrators
and officials are well intentioned
there's no data there there's no study
that says
no they're not well-intentioned they're
and it may be to be fair sometimes you
have to say is the
is if the claim is so obvious that
people would be
willing to grant it without more
argument then just
take it as stipulated sometimes that's
what lawyers sometimes say you know
i'll grant that claim as stipulated and
move on but but usually when we're in
this outline thing
every one of the things that a b c and d
should be a claim that's it has enough
controversy in it
that that you uh it's interesting that
it's interesting no i agree
and i hear this is you know one level
it's kind of obvious yeah these are all
human beings and no one's like darth
vader here well let's see if we can't
make it edgier
so so why do so they're well intentioned
so
so why do we think they're screwing up
because we kind of implicitly do think
they're screwing up yeah
i mean whenever i say someone is well
intentioned that user is implying that
they're not really sal is a very
well-meaning individual
that's exactly right exactly so so what
is it
but i think it's not obvious i think a
lot of times it's easy to demonize
people that you don't agree with correct
and uh when you meet them face to face
you realize that they're good people
with good intentions so let me try and
learn they're try to come from a good
place so let me try a claim that that
might be behind the claim we're making
here
which is that because you made it up
earlier if you actually if you pull down
to your uh pull the screen down to a
point you made up here
here this is a you said whenever these
people get worried
about the system their reaction is to
place more constraints on it
and i make it more rigid and i think
that's the idea
that that says first of all wow i think
that's true
and it's a command and control approach
to a problem
that i think you and i both believe does
not lend itself to a command and control
approach
so i would kind of and i mean this way
i'm thinking of the way
and you're right you said in the last
part this isn't how i would naturally
write so it's a really interesting
exercise for me
i i would i wouldn't like wait this this
statement right over here
i would kind of start off with like look
every administrator official governor
i've met
extremely well intentioned extremely you
know
like all they really care about is is
improving outcomes for students
not they're not trying to make anyone's
lives harder uh
and and and and maybe i'll give some
examples of that
but but then i would finish that
paragraph with however whenever the
public be the governor gets worried
about the education
the reaction is to place more
constraints on it make it more rigid now
give some
evidence for that uh well the evidence
is of
more more testing more dictating of what
the
the the i mean it's almost a assumed
going into this i mean
you know conti is already describing
this it's right this notion
and youth so that so when you're making
an argument we were closely into this
video too
when you're making an argument you have
to decide does this
do people will people grant me this
claim but if i just say it like i
certainly granted you that claim when
you said it if you if you didn't have to
one of the things you might do is go get
one of these
highly structured curricula with highly
structured tests that have
every lesson plan for every day
prescribed for the teacher and you
really literally are supposed to be a
robot
you know and say okay this is what we're
talking about that would be powerful for
actually i think
a a non-teacher to see what how
micromanaging some of these curricula
are yeah and when you do that it is
shocking so if we go back down to the
bottom of our thing then
what we've been doing in this in this
exercise and we've just been playing
with this uh
1a is we're organizing material by by
clustering it into these buckets and the
buckets cluster around claims the key
idea that
and as we had to discover our claim and
as you work on these things you realize
well that's not exactly
the claim i wanted and so that you keep
on doing and by searching for evidence
that makes you think well wait a minute
what
what's the real argument right the
evidence might change your claim because
it's evidence for you too
exactly and so this is what we this is
this is part of just the work of writing
and the organizing of writing